warm tributes are being paid around the
world to britain's queen elizabeth ii
who's died at 96. she was one of the
world's longest reigning monarchs and
heads of state her death means her son
charles has succeeded her he called his
mother's death a moment of the greatest
sadness for himself and the royal family
world leaders have been offering their
condolences german chancellor olaf
schultz said she was a role model and an
inspiration for millions of people while
u.s president joe biden said she was a
steadying presence in a world of
constant change meanwhile buckingham
palace has become a focus of national
mourning
they gathered in their thousands
to pay tribute
to their queen
it's a loss the country knew would come
yet the sense of shock and sadness
is palpable and profound
and we've all known just one queen
she's she's the person that we've always
looked up to
to myself
it's just a sad day
just a very very sad there
and she pledged her life to this country
and
she let in this country with great
reverence and duty and respect and honor
and i just don't know if that would be
another like her i'm not a royalist but
i think she was a mother for us all
wasn't she
she was the most wonderful inspiration
of the country
and being here today i'm honored
to sort of respect her
she just was leading
as an inspiration for women
the bedrock of british public life
for the last seven decades
the country and the commonwealth have a
new king and a new history to be made
but today is a time to reflect and mourn
the death of her majesty
queen elizabeth ii
our correspondent berget mas is in
london earlier she told me how people
there are reacting to the passing of the
queen and what's expected to happen in
the coming hours and days
the feeling is that uh this is really
the only thing that is in people's minds
at the moment so politics has more or
less ground uh hold and people have been
as you've shown flocking to buckingham
palace but also
i think just about everyone is is
touched by this because the queen has
just always been there for everyone
she's just been this monarch for seven
decades and i think many people
had the sense that you know she
it's quite it's impossible for her not
to be there and not to be the sort of
figurehead of the country
and now to be faced with the reality of
death i think for for a lot of people
it's also a reflection on on their own
grief that they would have
had over over the years their own
experiences maybe questions of death
that everyone is is trying to grapple
with i think this is
what's behind um that this is just
really such a big moment for the country
and for the british people
well as with all things royal the
protocol of the coming days will surely
be planned out in great detail what can
we
it is planning great detail however
there are still some insecurities
because the queen
has died in scotland and in balmoral and
now what's been carefully planned for
years and years um really meticulously
planned needs to be put to a test so
what we are expecting is that the body
will stay in scotland where the scottish
people will be able to pay their
respects and then in about
four or five days that
the body will then be transported to
london and she will be
in in the palace of westminster and then
the people can in london
pay their respects to to the queen and
this is all going to be a period of
mourning in which prince charles will
resume his official duty so we're
expecting him to give a broadcast his
first broadcast to the nation today i
think that will be a big moment and
then he will resume his activities he's
expected to travel all the nations to
travel to scotland and northern ireland
and wales and
basically
more or less introduce himself as the
new king and this is all going to happen
in the next days and then it's been
reported that within a fortnight there
will be the
actual funeral the state funeral for
queen elizabeth ii
having reigned for 70 years the queen
was a pillar of stability how dearly
will her stabilizing presence be missed
very very dearly terry it's a period of
such instability at the moment britain
has gone through a lot of turmoil
starting with a brexit referendum but
also more recently like other countries
britain has been exposed to to the war
in ukraine the war in europe to high gas
prices that's exacerbated problems that
a lot of british people have already had
the country has seen a period of
economic instability where wages have
been falling inflation has been rising
and this is expected to rise uh quite
dramatically within the next month so
it's a period where a lot of british
people really are quite hard done by uh
economically and where
um i don't think the queen would have
paid you know such a big um part in
their daily lives but just the the
presence that she that she has you know
she has you always been there and now to
to have to go to through a transition
and in the moment that's
already economically very difficult for
a lot of people that that will make it
just that little bit harder i think
berget thank you that was our
correspondent bigger mass in london
in a speech on her 21st birthday the
then heir to the throne princess
elizabeth promised to dedicate her life
to public service it was a promise she
kept to the end
just a few months ago britain marked her
70 years on the throne with a platinum
jubilee celebration and earlier this
week she appointed her 15th new prime
minister liz truss
here's a look at how the news of her
death was broken to the nation
a simple letter posted at the gates of
buckingham palace informing the public
that the queen had passed peacefully at
her scottish estate
and the country now has a king
as the news broke people were already
gathering outside the palace grounds
many had been waiting for updates on the
queen's condition
then flags fell to half-mast
also at 10 downing street flags were
lowered
prime minister liz truss just days into
her new job addressed the nation
we are all devastated by the news that
we have just heard from balmoral
the death of her majesty the queen
is a huge shock to the nation
and to the world
queen elizabeth ii was the rock on which
modern britain was built
our country has grown and flourished
under her reign
earlier in the day members of the royal
family had rushed to biba the queen's
side
several members flying into aberdeen
airport before making their way to queen
elizabeth's summer home in scotland
balmoral
all four of the queen's children were
there including the heir to the throne
prince charles now known as king charles
in an official statement charles said
that the family was mourning profoundly
the passing of a cherished sovereign
and a much-loved mother
tributes to the queen have already begun
to flood in from around the world
britain has lost its longest ever
serving monarch a leader who was for so
many a cornerstone of stability through
seven decades
i'm joined now in the studio by dw's
alex forrest whiting alex queen
elizabeth was on the throne for 70 years
she saw so much history
tell us about some of the highlights
some of the milestones in her life where
do we start with this terry she began as
queen when there was a british empire
and she died ice cream when there
certainly wasn't a british empire so um
she had has really seen um how britain
itself has changed as a huge global
power and then more of a mid-ranking
power now
during her reign the building of the
berlin wall the falling of the berlin
wall the falling of the soviet union i
mean it
it goes on and on the vietnam war how
many u.s presidents were there 14 u.s
presidents i think so and she met 13
including jeff kennedy um you know it
goes on and on and as we've just
heard before 15
british prime ministers including sir
winston churchill uh the wartime leader
and then on tuesday her 15th liz trust
so it is an extraordinary rain and so
much has changed during those 70 years
while she was on the throne
extraordinary indeed and her her reign
was remarkably um lacking in missteps at
least of her own
yeah i think that's pretty much fair to
say i think the missteps have
all really evolved around her personal
life or her certainly her family's
personal life and i would say the
biggest
problem that she faced where really her
popularity dipped was following the
death of princess diana that was king
charles's uh first wife she was killed
in a tragic car crash in 1997
and there was an absolute
outpouring of grief across the world but
particularly in the united kingdom and
the queen decided to stay in her
scottish residence at balmoral for a
week before she came down to
london so there was some criticism about
that and about her not really
understanding uh just what an important
uh time
moment this had been when diana died so
on the whole she really played the role
to perfection but there were a couple of
missteps certainly
we'll come back to you in just a moment
uh the queen's firstborn son
formerly prince charles is now the new
monarch to be known as king charles iii
he had this to say about his mother
the death of my beloved mother her
majesty the queen
is a moment of the greatest sadness for
me and all members of my family
we mom profoundly the passing of a
cherished sovereign and a much-loved
mother
i know her loss will be deeply felt
throughout the country the realms and
the commonwealth and by countless people
around the world
during this period of mourning and
change
my family and i will be comforted and
sustained by our knowledge of the
respect and deep affection in which the
queen was so widely held
royal observers have said they expect
charles's coronation to be quicker and
smaller than that of his mother and it's
an event he's had ample time to prepare
for let's take a look now at charles's
long wait to become king
he was dumped the perpetual prince
waiting to be king longer than any other
heir to the throne before him
[Music]
charles philip arthur george mountbatten
windsor was born in 1948
the first son of princess elizabeth
he was four years old at his mother's
coronation
queen elizabeth ii passes from the abbey
consecrated and dedicated to her life
work
[Music]
after attending boarding school and
graduating from cambridge university
charles continued royal tradition by
serving in the royal air force and royal
navy
[Music]
at 32 the world's most eligible bachelor
announced his engagement to lady diana
spencer 13 years as junior
just delighted and happy and i i'm
amazed that she's
been brave enough to take me on
the couple married in july 1981.
it was the wedding of the century and
captured the world's imagination
thousands came out to cheer and around
the globe hundreds of millions watched
the ceremony on their tv screens
[Applause]
where we go the couple had two sons
william and harry
but the fairy tale wasn't to last
charles and his wife seemed increasingly
unhappy
the press published leaked phone
conversations that showed charles was
having an affair with a former
girlfriend camilla parker-bowles
in 1992 they made their split official
it is announced from buckingham palace
that with regret the prince and princess
of wales have decided to separate
a year after the couple divorced diana
was killed in a car crash in paris after
being hounded by paparazzi
charles accompanied her body back to
britain
there was an outpouring of public grief
at diana's death
and with this scandal surrounding their
marriage not yet forgotten public
opinion of prince charles and the royal
family had never been so low
[Music]
charles continued to dedicate himself to
his royal duties and his charitable
causes
most notably the prince's trust a
charity he set up to help improve the
lives of disadvantaged young people
his relationship with camilla parker
bowles continued to develop
and in 2005 the couple were married in a
civil ceremony
together they have carried on charles
work on sustainability
he has always been passionate about the
environment promoting organic farming
and biodiversity on his estate
but also on a global stage
at the cop 26 climate summit in glasgow
he urged global leaders to do more to
limit global warming
the cost of inaction is far greater than
the cost of prevention time has quite
literally run out
as his mother stepped back from some of
her responsibilities in recent years
and especially after the death of his
father prince philip
charles took a more significant and
active part in discharging royal duties
from king and waiting to king and
training
now charles will take on the role that
he has been preparing for his entire
life
ndw's alex forest whiting is still with
me uh alex once the period of mourning
is over king charles will have some very
big shoes to fill do britain's think
he's up to the task well he has been
preparing for it for a very long time
but i think it's going to be very
difficult for him to ever
reach the popularity of his mother queen
elizabeth ii just because she was there
for 70 years and that obviously lasted
through thick and thin and prince
charles has had some
knocks to his popularities we saw in
that report most notably over that
affair with camilla parker-bowles even
though he was married to princess diana
and then what happened following the
death of princess diana so he's had to
build it that popularity and the respect
back up over the past uh two decades at
least and i think he certainly made
a good job of that he's done things like
he's tried to streamline the monarchy i
think we will see more of that in the
future and he's also trying to make sure
that everybody knows that prince william
is his heir and he's been lining up
prince william and kate who've been
doing many more uh duties on his behalf
and previously on the queen's behalf so
i think that he knows the audience he's
got to play to which is to promote the
younger generation
alex thank you very much that was dw's
alex forrest whitey
now in her seven decades on the throne
as britain's head of state queen
elizabeth ii met countless world leaders
now tributes are pouring in from across
the globe let's take a look at some of
them
lowering the flag in honor of queen
elizabeth a mark of respect from
president biden
i had the opportunity to meet her before
she passed and she was an incredibly
gracious and decent woman
the thoughts and prayers of the american
people
are with the people of the united
kingdom and the commonwealth and their
grief
other world leaders echoed those
sentiments as tributes flooded in
elizabeth
queen elizabeth was a woman who defined
a century in the united kingdom and
beyond
millions of germans are united in sorrow
and sympathy
with the people of the united kingdom
with deep sadness i have learned of the
death of her majesty queen elizabeth ii
it is a heavy loss for the whole of
europe and the world
from all ukrainians i express sincere
condolences to the royal family the
whole of the uk
and the commonwealth our thoughts and
prayers are with you
un secretary general antonio guterres
said that elizabeth would be remembered
for her unwavering lifelong dedication
scores of other leaders have rushed to
pay their respects to the woman who was
the face of a nation for so many years
you